[Música]
ah
hace un tiempo me pasó algo que no le
deseo a nadie es que me quedé sin
celular por una semana resulta que la
batería empezó a fallar y lo tuve que
mandar a arreglar y tardaron unos días
en devolverme lo
y conozco bien los síntomas de un
síndrome de abstinencia porque soy
fumador de esos que dejan el pucho y
vuelven a agarrar varias veces por año y
los primeros momentos de estar sin luz
sin celular fueron parecidos a los
primeros momentos de cuando uno deja de
fumar o decide dejar de fumar estaba
ansioso todo el tiempo no sabía qué
hacer con el tiempo muerto sentido a
vibraciones fantasmas en todo el cuerpo
me tocado los bolsillos productos porque
pensaba que haya perdido el teléfono o
el encendedor o los puchos pero así como
el los pulmones y la nariz se empiezan a
destapar cuando uno deja de fumar por
unos días sentí que después de unos días
sin teléfono el cerebro se ha empezado a
esta parte
entonces como yo no estaba metido
adentro de mi rectángulo personal de luz
como dice un amigo veía como casi todos
a mi alrededor estaban metidos adentro
de su rectángulo personal de luz en
salas de espera en colas del banco
manejando
caminando por la calle todos hay adentro
no vengo a plantear una vida offline ni
vengo a pararme aquí y decir que
encontré la sabiduría y la iluminación
porque estuve cinco días sin teléfono
a parte porque sería el menos indicado
para hacerlo uso computadoras hace 30
años desde que tengo 7 soy programador
profesional hace casi 20
tengo cuenta de facebook hace 12 años
del 2006 tengo twitter desde el 2007
desde esa época publiqué casi 24 mil 500
tweets
calculó el tiempo promedio que me llevo
escribir cada uno y lo multiplicó por
24.500 no lo quiero hacer porque me
deprimiría
pero bueno recupere el celular y entre
las cosas que se me ocurrieron porque no
estaba dentro de mi rectángulo de luz
mirando un vídeo de un perro andando en
patineta o peleándome con un desconocido
o indignando me y compartiendo mi
indignación este portal lo cual noticia
como tenía tiempo se me ocurrieron
algunas cosas porque pensaba no porque
estaba ahí adentro
finalmente como soñaron los pioneros de
la computación personal hace casi 60
años en los años 60 la mayor parte de la
humanidad tiene acceso irrestricto a un
dispositivo de cómputo muy potente que
encima está conectado de manera
inalámbrica a una red global de
telecomunicaciones de alta velocidad que
se llama internet
esos pioneros tenían una idea muy clara
computadoras para todos y todos pioneros
como jcr licklider que fue el impulsor
de la creación de internet
douglas engelbart inventó el mouse y
muchos mecanismos de interacción humano
computadora que usamos todos los días
tener son que formalizó y conceptualizó
la idea de hipertexto que es fundamental
para la web o alan kay que fue creador
también de muchos conceptos tecnologías
y paradigmas que hoy damos por sentados
todos ellos pensaron a la computadora
personal como una herramienta de
expansión de nuestras capacidades de
liberación y de creatividad y pensaron
en la computación personal en clara
oposición al paradigma de su época
cuando las computadoras no eran
personales las computadoras eran muy
grandes muy caras y por lo tanto
solamente las tenían los militares las
universidades y las grandes empresas
y todos los grandes visionarios para ser
visionarios tienen que ser muy
optimistas de otra manera no serían
visionarios
y por ejemplo tanto tener son como alan
que están vivos y están un poco
decepcionados porque la mejor
herramienta que creó la humanidad hasta
el momento en mi opinión la computadora
personal se está transformando en un
artefacto apenas un poco mejor que un
televisor en una herramienta de consumo
los medios sociales en los que
invertimos gran parte de nuestro día
están transformando estar administrando
que están arbitrando lo que consumimos
la cultura que consumimos lo que vemos
lo que leemos lo que escuchamos están
más o menos determinando con quién nos
relacionamos y de la manera en la que
nos relacionamos
y lo hacen a través de estos mecanismos
que se llaman algoritmos seguramente
habrán escuchado esa palabra
por ejemplo quizá no sepan que todo que
lo que vemos en la pantalla principal de
la mayoría de las redes sociales
facebook por ejemplo no es todo lo que
publican nuestros contactos es apenas
una parte muy pequeña que está
selecciona está seleccionada está curada
por un algoritmo y qué son los
algoritmos más allá de definiciones
técnicas del libro de texto un algoritmo
es una máquina entran materias primas
por un lado sale un producto por el otro
en el caso de los algoritmos de
recomendación los algoritmos que nos
sugieren qué cultura consumir en la
barrita del costado de youtube o la
página principal de facebook esa materia
prima son los datos los datos de todos
sus usuarios jesús tiene varios miles de
millones de usuarios esa es la materia
prima de ese algoritmo el producto el
bien que generan esas máquinas es una
selección de todo el contenido
disponible que quizás nos puede
interesar
y quiero detenerme en ese punto en
particular los algoritmos corren en
computadoras y todo lo que sale de una
computadora tiene una cierta connotación
neutral no porque lo produce una máquina
eso no es así los métodos automáticos
los algoritmos los resultados de un
programa complejo de computadoras cuando
se aplican a cuestiones complejas como
por ejemplo arbitrar que cultura
consumen miles de millones de personas
en todo el mundo no son neutrales porque
los algoritmos están creados por
personas y las personas pertenecen a una
cultura y por lo tanto tienen prejuicios
y tienen opiniones y tienen una manera
determinada de ver al mundo
les voy a mostrar un ejemplo es a veces
yo igual a winnie y es investigadora de
lehman y media helada porque yo también
pasé de hace dos años
yo hoy para su proyecto de investigación
a uno de sus proyectos se puso a jugar
con un sistema de reconocimiento facial
y descubrió que ese sistema no detectaba
su cara porque porque es negra y eso no
habla de una limitación fundamental del
método que estaba usando no habla de una
limitación de la computadora en la que
estaba corriendo ese programa ni de la
cámara ni de la luz que había en la
habitación cuando estaba probando eso
los sistemas de reconocimiento facial
los que usan hoy en día son sistemas que
pertenecen a la clase que se llama my in
learning o aprendizaje automatizado o si
queremos hablar en el idioma del
marketing inteligencia artificial
esos sistemas necesitan ser entrenados
uno escribe un programa relativamente
simple más o menos y después lo entrena
en el caso de estos sistemas le
mostramos un montón de imágenes y por
qué alguna de le decimos si contiene una
cara o no contiene una cara y se
contiene una cara dónde está esa cara el
propósito de esto es generar un modelo
estadístico cuya finalidad va a ser
decirnos si una imagen que demostramos
tiene una cara o no y si la tiene dónde
está esa cara
como ya se imaginarán el sistema que
estaba usando yo hoy cuando fue
entrenado
no le mostraron caras negras es decir
que para este sistema la cara de joy no
era una cara
hay muchos ejemplos de esto que se está
empezando a llamar sesgos algorítmicos
no podríamos decir
prejuicios algorítmicos por ejemplo el
traductor automático de google que es el
que es el más usado cuando traduce un
idioma que no usa género a un idioma que
si usa género por ejemplo del inglés al
español hace cosas como traducir the
engineer a el ingeniero yo la ingeniera
de nerd sea la enfermedad no el
enfermero entonces ahí hay una carga
cultural hay una decisión porque
obviamente él
los datos que se usaron para entrenar el
sistema provienen de la cultura a la que
pertenecen sus diseñadores
otro ejemplo es un sistema que evaluaba
riesgo crediticio un caso que fue
estudiado periodística y académicamente
y estaba sesgado hacia personas de
ciertas razas de ciertas dos personas
con iguales características salvo su
raza la raza determinaban mayor riesgo
crediticio eso es un sesgo en nuestro
país sin ir más lejos hace poco un
político anunció con bombos y platillos
que tenía un sistema de inteligencia
artificial dijo el que podía predecir
casos individuales de embarazo
adolescente un tema muy relevante por lo
que estamos discutiendo hoy en día como
sociedad es decir algo que parecía de
ciencia ficción se estaba discutiendo en
los programas de la tarde la idea de que
una computadora incida en decisiones
individuales y muy sensibles de política
pública
ahora bien los algoritmos no son
neutrales porque sus creadores por ser
seres humanos no son neutrales no
podemos neutrales
entonces qué hacemos no usamos
algoritmos yo creo que esta no es una
opción porque tienen muchos beneficios
pero al ser introducidos masivamente y
sin entenderlos demasiado bien todavía
tenemos que pensar algunas cosas y ser
cuidadosos en particular por ejemplo el
concepto de responsabilidad imagínense
qué va a pasar porque esto va a pasar
cuando un auto que está comandado un
auto autónomo que está comandado
obviamente por una computadora tome una
decisión
que produzca un accidente fatal dada una
situación en la que tiene que doblar
para allá o para allá para no provocar
un accidente mayor en cualquiera de los
dos casos mata a alguien a quien va a
matar y cuando lo haga quien será
responsable la persona que va dentro del
auto no porque no está manejando la
persona que hizo el algoritmo no
probablemente sean 500 personas que
hayan hecho ese algoritmo el dueño de la
empresa eso es un tema que se
investigaba también en el media lago
cuando yo estaba ahí
entonces los dispositivos y los
algoritmos son espejos de la cultura en
la que son construidos por ejemplo la
mayor parte de los algoritmos que están
incidiendo en la producción y consumo
global de cultura se producen en una
zona específica del mundo casi todos que
es la zona de san francisco en
california
un lugar en el que por ejemplo tu
familia de 4 tiene que ganar más de 10
mil dólares por mes para no ser
considerada de bajos ingresos por el
estado diez mil dólares por mes desde
esa cultura desde esa realidad se está
incidiendo en la producción y consumo
global de cultura
qué hacer con todo esto entonces es
un poco difícil pensar en términos de
una solución a un problema porque es una
situación muy compleja y con muchas
sutilezas
porque la escala y el alcance y la
profundidad de tecnología hacen que sea
muy difícil de plantear como un problema
ser resuelto
yo creo que podemos empezar siendo
conscientes de algunas cosas en primer
lugar los grandes monopolios de internet
las grandes empresas que producen los
sistemas masivos de internet que usamos
todos los días necesitan de nuestra
información fresca todo el tiempo porque
esa es su materia prima de eso dependen
para sobrevivir y para ganar plata y
para pagar los sueldos y para reportar
dividendos a sus accionistas
entonces están diseñados para que los
usemos constantemente desde el diseño de
estos sistemas se están se están
incentivando conductas adictivas
por ejemplo las notificaciones de los
teléfonos facebook te avisa muchas redes
sociales te avisan que el primo segundo
de tu vecina subió una foto del gato de
su suegra entonces suena el teléfono
sacamos el teléfono vemos al gatito le
ponemos me gusta y terminamos pasando
nos media hora ahí a dentro de nuestros
rectángulos personales de luz
alimentando tanto la base de datos del
sistema que estamos usando como cientos
de bases de datos de muchas empresas que
no sabemos dónde están para que usan los
datos y a quién se los venden los que
los cambian y los combinas y los
revenden
yo creo que también otra cosa que se
puede hacer con esta situación es
recuperar la visión original de la
computación personal que planteaba de
vuelta a los mejores las mejores
herramientas que inventamos como
humanidad hasta el momento como recursos
de creación de liberación y de expansión
de nuestras capacidades
steve jobs hablaba de una bicicleta para
la mente
y como en todas las cosas es mejor
empezar desde chicos muchas veces
pensamos y nos conformamos pensando que
los chicos nacen sabiendo usar la
computadora eso para mí es mentira nadie
nace sabiendo nada uno enseña es natural
que los chicos aprendan más rápido
porque están rodeados de artefactos y
nos ven a nosotros usándolos pero si no
tienen una guía lo más probable es que
tanto chicos como grandes se limiten a
usar los artefactos las computadoras y
los teléfonos y cualquier recurso
interactivo digital de la manera en que
se lo proponen sus fabricantes y nada
más y yo creo que la innovación
tecnológica esa idea tan de moda que le
gusta decir a los políticos y a los
consultores y a los periodistas que
están medio vacías ya de sentido
sucede cuando la tecnología se subvierte
cuando se usa para otra cosa cuando se
resignifica
y eso es un poco el verdadero
significado de el concepto de hacking o
del espíritu hacker la idea de
intervenir creativamente en un
dispositivo de resignificar lo de poder
desarmarlo de cambiarlo y sobre todo de
militar por el libre flujo del
conocimiento aprendiendo entre pares
eso pasa en un lugar que hay mayor
blanca que se llama infinito por
descubrir que es genial en el que chicos
van allí y se apropian de la tecnología
la cambian la desarman la combinan con
otras cosas no solamente programando
sino haciendo robots y haciendo
producciones audiovisuales y música y
diseño industrial y un montón de cosas
entonces así como tuvimos que aprender a
dominar la tecnología de la
lectoescritura o qué es una tecnología y
eso nos dio ventaja tendremos que
aprender a dominar tecnología digital
porque eso también nos da ventaja
los algoritmos que rigen cada vez más
aspectos de nuestras vidas
son creados por personas como yo y
probablemente como algunos existen acá
dentro entonces hay que perderles el
miedo y saber que esas máquinas no son
neutrales tienen sesgos y tienen
opiniones porque las personas que las
construimos los tenemos
no es todo malo las redes sociales
tienen cosas buenas por ejemplo una de
las cosas que yo más rescato es
optimizan la comunicación entre grandes
grupos de gente entonces se pueden
coordinar acciones mucho más
eficientemente eso hizo que surgieron
nuevos movimientos sociales desde las
redes sociales esto es una cosa positiva
nos ayudan a buscar trabajo nos llevan a
buscar pareja aprendemos un montón de
cosas
pero la concentración de los recursos
tecnológicos en pocas manos sumada a la
escala y profundidad que tenemos produce
efectos muy sutiles y muy complejos que
no hemos sido capaces de prever como
sociedad ni siquiera los responsables de
estos sistemas las empresas que
administran y construyen las redes
sociales fueron capaces de prever los
entonces por eso están dando en los
últimos meses algunos manotazos de
ahogados para tratar de mitigar todas
estas cosas
entonces como humanidad generamos un
montón de nuevas instituciones que nos
permitieron organizarnos mejor entre
nosotros inventamos el gobierno
inventamos la democracia inventamos las
leyes en el siglo 19 y 20 inventamos los
medios masivos de comunicación porque
unos siglos antes había aparecido la
imprenta
y todas esas nuevas instituciones
generaron nuevas profesiones surgieron
los políticos profesionales surgieron
los abogados que son los que son capaces
de decodificar el código legal surgieron
los periodistas y también surgió la
necesidad de criticar y de someter a
examen ya exigirles cosas a estas nuevas
instituciones de tanto poder concentrado
como los gobiernos y los medios masivos
de comunicación los sistemas masivos de
comunicación social en internet son
nuevas instituciones entonces tenemos
que ser capaces de hablar su idioma
tenemos que ser capaces de entenderlas
y para poder someterlas a juicio y
someterlas a crítica y exigirle
transparencia y exigir la
responsabilidad por sus acciones y para
eso hay que ser un poco hacker porque
como dice ger a un amigo programador y
maestro de programadores hackers o
dominados
[Aplausos]
[Música]